appreciate the effort I put into the
title I really wanted to fit into the
theme of the workshop okay so as I
understand there are some students here
who are in a computer science students
who is trying to get a feeler for the
field so I'll spend a little more time
on the motivation then I would have
otherwise so my talk will be all about
transcriptional regulation and why do we
care so the big million-dollar you know
reason why we are doing what we are
doing is this link here from genotype to
phenotype right how differences in our
genome manifest themselves in
differences in phenotypes and most of us
will agree that this this link from
genotype to phenotype in large part goes
through this thing called transcriptome
so the genetic genetic differences lead
to difference in transcriptome which in
turn through crazy nonlinear
relationships here manifests and
surfaces phenotypes differences and at
all levels the diversity in nature the
underlying cause is transcriptional
regulation so that's why we care about
this process
so set up the scene of what all goes on
a transcriptional regulation how genes
are turned on specific conditions the
lots of things goes on but I just want
you to focus right now on specific thing
called interaction between these
transcription factors to the DNA and
that happens in many different places in
the genome specifically near the gene
that gene starts at the promoter but
more recently we are we know that it
happens very critically very far away
from the genes as well especially for
the genes that are highly
condition-specific so my focus will be a
lot on this part here so just to zoom in
a little bit on distal enhancers this is
a poster child of what we when we talk
about distal enhancers is a sonic
hedgehog gene and its enhancer is
located about one mega base away in the
info on of some other gene how would we
ever find this out as crazy right and
single nucleotide mutations here can
result in extra you know fingers this is
that important
okay so with that quick background that
three quick stories owl everybody always
presents this song eh okay examples
there are many other exam so everybody
presents this one because this is a
farthest enhancer known and there are
lots and lots of experimental data in
many many mammalian species where
polymorphisms in this enhancer have been
shown to result in deformation so that's
the reason but there are many other
examples not as Extreme as this and the
phenotypic consequences is not as
Extreme as this but there many examples
for sure at this stage for sure okay so
the first talk part of the talk will be
this relationship between you know snips
and gene expression and I can turn it
around and say the same thing
relationship between enhancers and jeans
so that takes us to this field called
genome-wide Association studies so what
is it so it's basically we have two
groups of people affected and unaffected
or for some phenotype of interest and we
are looking at one polymorphism at a
time and asking whether there is a very
differential allele frequencies between
the two groups and if they do then we
have somewhere to go in terms of looking
for cause of this disease or phenotype
okay if if my phenotype happens to be
gene expression for a specific gene then
this whole thing is called eqtl
expression quantitative trait loci so
same thing you're looking at one snip
here and we are asking given the
genotype at that snip are the expression
levels very different in individuals who
have this genotype versus this genotype
or set this genotype okay so that's
expression eqtl for you
so a big problem with this whole jiva's
and eqtl any kind of large-scale
Association study is that that's all
they are their associations right not
causality and big part of that reason is
this thing's called linkage
disequilibrium so there are large
regions of the genome that through
evolution have traveled together as a
molecule so all the polymorphism in this
piece of DNA are linked so they don't
give you any additional information so
you cannot distinguish one from the
other when it comes down to causality
because they have exactly same
association with the whatever phenotype
we are looking at so that's one big
problem and second problem is even when
you find these signals it's very
difficult to go and interpret them
exactly how they affect the phenotype or
gene expression but unlike general
phenotypes in case of whenever phenotype
is gene expression we know a lot about
the mechanism of transcriptional
regulation so the idea behind this
project is to bring in everything we
know to do a better job at dealing with
these two major problems ok because
functional interpretation is built in
the model itself so anything we are
detecting will have a specific
interpretation to begin with
so the basic idea in a nutshell is this
so we have lots of snips that may be
associated with the expression of a gene
okay and the goal is to distinguish
among them which is more likely to be
the causal polymorphism and we bring in
all kinds of additional biological
information grounded in the mechanistic
understanding of this process the two
classes of information we bring in in
the model one is how likely is are these
individual snips to be a regulator i
distill enhancer okay so we have lots of
epigenomic data now that tell us
specific combinations of them correspond
to enhancer activity so the bring in all
this data this is one kind of
information even when it is an enhancer
who is to say that it actually regulates
that gene and not some other gene so now
we have this we have to bring in another
kind of feature set which link this
location to this gene right so we have
you know you can think of 3d interaction
you can think about the correlation
between what happens at this low sigh
across conditions and what happens to
this gene expression the two kinds of
interaction features that we bring in we
put all this into a vision hierarchical
Bayesian framework and try to solve it
there are more technical tricks that I'm
happy to admit that my student knows
much more than I do so but but I would
defer to him okay with more technical
details so it's basically coupled
Bayesian model so knowing the model for
enhancers which based on all these
epigenomic data helps us home in on
specific snips and knowing which snips
our regulators helps us define this
model so there is a back and forth
between these two models and it
converges so a quick application so data
we had access to where 300 human heart
from both failed heart and healthy heart
and all that but we are not making that
distinction right now and we had
genotype and gene expression
and we got all kinds of histone
modification and other kind of epidemic
data from encode for heart specific
tissues and cell types the statistics
first then we'll come to biology so in
terms of how much of expression variance
is explained by the model okay so we are
comparing our method with few other
method only going to show here to
representative one is just a standard
multi-bit multi regression lasso and one
is tool from Jonathan pritchards group
called EQT and minor that is the closest
to what we are doing it does take into
account prior that depends on the IP
genomic signals so that's that's how
comparing with this so in terms of just
the explained variance we see that there
is a big difference in terms of how much
of the variance is explained and in this
two plots here what we are trying to the
message here is that all the snip arrays
or since we look at our tiny fraction of
all the polymorphisms right these are
tagged snips so typically people impute
the snips so we have ten times more
sniffs now but the people have made this
point that you have to look at imputed
set of snips to really get to the causal
ones right so when you impute them you
have even a bigger problem the the
haystack is even bigger to find the
needle in and that's when power of these
methods where you are using the known
mechanism comes into play very strongly
now to the biology so how do we know yes
please go back to the method in points
what makes it different from the other
right right so okay the two main things
one is ok so the just to make the
contrast between the acuity and minor
what it does is it makes it relies on a
prior model of what enhancer looks like
okay so for each gene it looks at the
strongest associated snip okay within a
200 kb or something of the gene that's
one limitation right away using the
strongest snip for every gene
it builds an epigenomic based model of
what enhancer should look like so there
is no back and forth and it applies that
model and broadens the scope and then
fits the Beijing model again what we are
doing is number one we are looking at a
much broader region we are not relying
on a specific model of enhancer we are
letting the model itself be
heterogeneous through MCMC sampling and
so the and also the way we are doing
sampling takes very specific care of LD
blocks we are making sure that the
representatives from each LD blocks are
fairly sampled so those are the three
main reasons why we think we are doing
better and in the paper we have tried to
make this argument individually but are
you using the information known enhancer
locations or are you doing it for
everything within this mega base we had
everything within this mega all snips
also at all snip locations like
afterthought but big big big that's
right that's a good point that's a good
point but that's a good point here so
okay so there is a model fall you see if
there is a picture right so there is a
enhancer gene interaction model right so
given the location of the enhancer the
snip and the gene so I can say okay what
is the correlation between dnase
hypersensitivity for example at this
location across many many different cell
types and the gene expression right so
these are kinds of things that go in the
model
okay so the first the first thing we
asked was the sniffs we find versus you
know sniffs you would find otherwise is
there a clear difference in terms of
evidence of protein binding right so
there is something called DNA's
footprint data these are high resolution
high depth DNA's experiments where you
can look at indentations in the signal
any indentation indicates binding of
some protein so just as a basic
assessment how what fraction of what we
are calling a snip show this indentation
okay show something binding there so
that's number one so these are in we did
that in many many cell types and so the
first one for example we take the union
of all heart-related issue for which
this footprint data is available and we
ask what fraction of what we are calling
a snip and by the way we control for the
number of snips we are picking obviously
it's like you know most of the things
what we are detecting even though we
don't use footprint itself in the model
at all we are using other indications of
the enhancer wide signals but at that
location specific location we are seeing
greater in dentate a fraction of
indentations evidence of protein binding
but could you read it in your model your
new things yeah nothing in our model is
at that resolution at all everything in
our model is the 500 base pair
resolution but here we are assessing at
that 20 base pair or 10 base pair five
base pair in too often for muffin
overall you have lost nips in enhancers
in in open chromatin yeah
make it more wedding dress right that's
true but the thing is the EQT and minor
also is looking at the open chromatin
only control is there so this is motive
disruption what I mean by that so we
asked for each known binding motif that
we are aware of we asked and for for a
given slip we can we can you know
calculate the difference in binding
energy for snip a versus snippy and if
that binding energy difference is too
much above the threshold we call it
disrupted so for each transcription
factor we ask how much is it disrupted
genome-wide by the snips we are
detecting and we rank all the
transcription factors based on that and
this i'm just showing the rank list here
so so this is basically all the red ones
are known core cardiac transcription
factors and i did some literature search
and all the blue ones there are clear
indications of their involvement in gene
regulation in cardiomyocytes or heart
tissue so this checks out nicely and
then getting to more specifics like if
we are claiming that these snips are
causal then we better see a allelic
effect right so we are just looking at
the dnase hypersensitivity in that
region and asking how different are are
these signals for the two alleles we are
just calculating the allelic difference
so that that checks out and lastly we
are in this particular run of the model
we did not use the 3d interaction data
directly we did not use the chia pet or
3 C or whatever so here we are actually
asking what is the evidence of 3d
interaction between the snip we are
calling and it's a purported target gene
okay so that was a quick story number
one now we move on to enhancer enhancer
interaction so this work was done a few
years ago already and the idea is very
simple so we have been talking about
gene coexpression regulatory networks
and these kinds of things where you look
at two genes and see how they go up and
down across conditions or tissues and
you do correlation and you have a
network so we the data had just become
available so it seemed it made sense to
just do that for enhancers right so like
in gene V we are calculating the
expression of the gene across conditions
how do we proxy enhancer activity so
just at that time the simplest thing we
could do was just look at the open
closed status dnase hypersensitivity of
this enhancer across conditions or cell
types so just based on that simple idea
we looked at the correlation with the
the only methodological a trick we have
to do was very carefully control for
this propensity of things that are
nearby in the genome to be nearby in
space as well so that overwhelms the
signal as you can imagine so we very
carefully accounted for that and then we
applied this very stringent FDR and all
that is just an example here so these
are each line here is an enhancer
throughout the genome it is a very large
region in a couple of hundred mega bases
and in these three cell types these are
on in these two cell types they're off
so these enhancers will be part of the
highly correlated cluster for example so
we apply all these controls and stuff
and we find highly correlated enhancer
pairs and clusters and we look at what
are the properties of these things
because that leads into my next project
so these are the main things we found so
first of all the first question was do
they share anything the things that are
highly correlated and yes they do but
more interesting thing is the second
point here ok so the enhancers that are
very far on the genome and an answer
that are close by relatively the one
that are far have much greater
transcription factor binding sites
sharing
so there is a very specific mechanism
apparently for things that are very far
and come together in space or whatever
because we didn't control completely for
the business decision how would that
lead to this result because your
correlations or nearby and answers are
not as trustworthy as correlation for
father nonsense but by the way the
vendor when I say nearby here I'm not
talking about the nearby that you would
do without the control the nearby in
that context would be you know 50 kb 20
kb that kind of thing these are still
megabass away versus 10 mega base away
that kind of distance resolution we're
talking about here but yeah there's
something to look into for sure other
thing we found is that the and had the
binding sites that are preferentially
shared between these correlated
enhancers interact with very specific
chromatin modification enzyme so that
was another question right how are they
impacting correlated activity of
enhancers and one obvious thought was
well maybe they interact with chromatin
modification and change the status of
all these things that are nearby and
lastly we again check these correlated
enhancers tend to be together in space
so at that time the 3c data or hi-c data
was available only for two tissues so we
just based on those there is a big
differential in in 3d proximity of this
correlated enhancer versus uncorrelated
ok just an example of enhancer and gene
clusters so what the model we are
thinking in terms of so the bottom line
for the cells functioning is this
correlated act activity of genes how it
is achieved is what we are after right
now ok so the thought here is that one
direct route would be if you had you
know in the regulatory regions of this
jeans if you have shared transcription
factor binding sites that would be
easiest way to make their activity
correlated right that's one but what we
are also thinking is that maybe there is
the link between this and this is in
maybe motif sharing somehow affects the
3d proximity that may affect directly or
indirectly here the enhancer activity
correlation and that would of course
directly affect their target gene
correlated activity so this is the model
we are thinking about this so what so
you can draw a network of gene
expression correlation right that is
based on motive sharing and you can go
one that is more careful and based on
your knowledge of enhancers and how the
impact expression I'll different all
these networks direct gened correlation
expression network and enhancer a
network ah it has a base gene expression
network no yeah I guess I'm saying how
much contribution to be right right
right right so simple promoters
promoters yeah yeah yeah that's it very
good that's a good question i have not
specifically asset but they're like
quantifying the contribution of each of
these i don't know if i have time we can
get back to this question is slightly
tangential so last part is what is done
we are trying to get it published but
it's a little bit you know out there so
we'll see what is the audience reaction
here so the
people are really interested in what
makes a transcription factor binding to
a specific region location in vivo in
the cell right so there is a distinction
between in vitro what can happen in vivo
what does happen right so if you just
put the TF and the and the DNA and it
tests you band shake it it might bind
right but it doesn't bind in real life
so what are the additional determinants
of of that in vivo binding is of great
interest and these are the kinds of
things people have gone down answering
this question so the DNA motif itself is
you know about 20 base pairs it doesn't
have a lot of information content it
just cannot explain the in vivo binding
specifically people binding that that
well obviously other thought people have
is of course they got they work together
so this cooperative bindings if you look
at combinations of these things then it
explain a little bit more specificity
people have looked at general nature of
the DNA around the in vivo bound
locations versus non-controlling for the
the binding motif itself that's another
and here is local chromatin state open
closed all these things and then this is
the most interesting for us the
homotypic clusters of binding sites so
these are you know same binding site for
the same transcription factor occurring
in clusters within a very short region
few hundred base pairs and these are
known to be a you know of charring Co
has shown that these are characteristics
of enhancers it happens a lot okay and
then people in biophysica the community
have shown that through modeling this
thing called TF diffusion a facilitated
diffusion where it comes and binds one
of those places and it just goes along
the genome it kept before it goes too
far it is right this kind of trapped
locally so that may increase the
robustness of binding by simply having
multiple binding sites it has also been
shown that evolution from the
evolutionary perspective it's easier to
evolve three lousy sites than to evolve
one really strong site these are the
reasons that goes behind the huge
prevalence of these things call
homotypic clusters of binding sites so
we are taking this idea little further
now so what we are proposing is or
speculating is what happens when you
bring these binding sites that are very
far in the genome together in space at
the same time right so in effect it's
doing what H CTS do but now it's a
spatial clustering as opposed to genomic
clustering and the advantage of such a
thing would be it could become very
condition-specific if you have just a
genomic cluster it's a static thing you
cannot do much with it right it will
only depend on the P of concentration
but if you have them differently then
you have PF concentration as one of the
determinants and the 3d proximity as a
another dimension when they come
together it works when they don't it
does not so that's the thought process
behind this project so we are simply
going to ask when after controlling for
the binding affinity that describes the
in vitro binding affinity controlling
for that do we see a higher occupancy in
vivo occupancy when things are close
together in space versus then they are
not that's the question and how do we
quantify in vivo occupancy we do that
using this thing again called footprints
so footprints so just an example we have
all these footprints and we overlay
using very stringent criteria these
motifs on to these footprints and if we
see that then we call it occupied by
that transcription factor if we don't
then we don't and we are quantifying
among all the places where it could bind
how many of them are occupied so the
fractional occupancy that's what we are
calculating and we are comparing that
fractional occupancy between the two
conditions when they are closed and when
they are not so we call this occupancy
boost how much more the occupancy is
controlling for all these other
confounders
so both because we are talking about a
3d cluster of enhancer elements so we
have predefined these clusters they are
ascertained that that indeed close in
three dimension and then that's our
space in that space we look at all the
binding sites for a one transcription
factor and we calculate how many of them
are actually occupied and we have a
control set of same number of enhancers
with all other properties exactly
matched in terms of chromatin
accessibility in terms of GC content and
all these things and we ask what
fraction of that binding site is
occupied when they are not in 3d space
together so that's the comparison so so
we are showing in two dimension that
effect of lots of binding sites in space
on the in vivo occupancy boost so the
first dimension is the enhancer sighs
how many enhancers are there in the in
the archipelago we call it the cluster
or archipelago and here in this
dimension it's the mean binding number
of binding sites / enhancer just to show
that it's not just because of a lot of
dense clusters concentrated in few
enhancers is truly a distribution across
many many spatially proximal but
genomically distal locations so there's
a huge increase in occupancy after
controlling for all these other things
so almost two hundred ten percent which
is like twofold threefold threefold on
that so two hundred percent will be
threefold occupancy increase
then we also just to get little bit more
honest grounded grounded things into
real mechanism we hooked up with Boris
Adrian's group at Cambridge because he's
the one who did the facilitated
diffusion modeling for homotypic
clusters so we asked them to see if they
can extend that model to see the effect
of three-dimensional proximity so the
direct control here is you set up your
system and you're directly comparing the
occupancy boost when they are very close
when they are not so close when they are
very far so said and we are we are
changing things like how many holes
individual sites are their input and
answer and how many enhancers are
together in that space so the two
parameters we control and this is highly
computationally intensive process hence
these numbers here but nevertheless in
no matter how you look at it there is a
huge occupancy boost when things are
together compared to when they are not
so the model was extended in a way that
in addition to just crawling along the
g8 the DNA it can also jump to a nearby
side when they're close enough in space
great so now we have this cluster of
enhancers the question then was are all
enhancers in these clusters made the
same do they have their individual
identity in some way are they all
affected equally and for that we try to
distinguish between the enhancers that
have lots of binding sites for something
of which there is a lot off in that
cluster versus the ones which don't so
we call these enriched enhancers and we
call this depleted enhancers within the
same cluster and we compare these two in
terms of what is their chromatin
accessibility what is their evolutionary
conservation what is the expression of
their downstream gene and we find clear
difference specifically for the enhancer
subset which are enriched in these
highly abundant binding sites in the
archipelago so that's what this is
trying to say so next the question was
in a cause and effect so it is known in
the literature that when lots of TF
binds by whatever means in a region it
affects the overall accessibility of
that region and likewise other other
direction is even more obvious so the
question was what what is this chicken
and the egg question here right so but
fortunately we can break this cycle by
specifically looking at effect of PF
gene expression of the transcription
factor on the boost right if you see an
effect then that would imply this
causality
so that's what this is trying to do so
we divide up all our transcription
factors in a particular tissue in terms
of highly expressed and less highly
expressed and look at the occupancy
boost of the ones that have high
expression versus the ones which have
which do not have I expression and we
see this occupancy boost effect only for
the TFS that have high expression not
the ones which are low expression that
sort of points to that causality so
putting it all together what we are
claiming here is that you can have these
you know HC tease or homotypic clusters
of binding sites just lollygagging
around in the genome doing nothing they
have to be not only brought together in
space like this but also the specific
transcription factor expression has to
be there for for this effect to take
place and in the same condition some
other parts of genome where you have
everything other than this spatial
proximity the effect will not work so
this is the idea where so this kind of
really changes the way if I don't know
what fraction of control of gene
expression this contributes to but
whatever it is it's like a different way
of thinking about adding one more thing
to the whole complex mechanistic the
story of the transcription like now we
have to think about what is nearby in
space and why not right
so those for the three quick stories I
talked about and I'm happy to take
questions and all this work was done
better by two grad students now they're
postdocs as fair access to the noise of
the noise of the gene okay very sweet if
i had to guess if I had to put money on
it I would guess that will make it
robust as opposed to noisy that would be
my guess but that's excellent I don't
know I don't know the answer in fact
just to add on to what we don't know so
people have now found these gene and all
these enhancers based on various 3d
asses but we don't know the relationship
between how these enhancers are
controlling the expression of this gene
what is the relationship between what
function what is the underlying function
like mathematical function we don't know
so to question first of all how is this
related to the classical that's an
excellent that's an excellent point so
in our paper in the discussion we do say
that it transcription factories you know
they are few papers that experimentally
talk a look at concentration is Pacific
nuclear areas and based on that this
theory has evolved right but there is no
database of transcription factories
right so our speculation is that this is
the mechanism for transcription factory
and we also have in the paper looked at
the relationship between these think of
super enhancers which are high
concentration of enhancers in a genomic
region and what we are claiming is that
this mechanism sits on top of super
enhancer it can link multiple super
enhancers together so yeah
look at the IC day that most of the
contacts are Caroline not multi watch
what's the distribution of the number of
say right right right right so that was
part for filtering so we start with just
the correlation based clusters and we
then prune that cluster based on hi-c
data only to keep the clusters where
eighty percent of all pairs are close by
based on the stringent hi-c
determination so these in these what a
size of these enhancers it can be in the
mean would be in hundreds lots of dozens
dozens of of enhancers same cluster
highly correlated expression activity
and eighty percent of all pairs being in
high C amazes
but I mean you you you can always do the
planar thing it doesn't have to be sighs
and all that sounds right right right
right yeah no that's not that's a good
question so we we just looked at hi-c
data and say okay ours is detected
especially close based on their FDR but
the distances yeah but the distances I
don't know the what does it claim on the
distance between these two things and if
the distance is too little then you what
you are saying is right is impossible to
have all these things close by but these
are open flushes I do not know we can
take more questions in the break let's
thank the speaker again